what is up guys mtic over here today I'm
going to show you how to program keys
for your Infinity I have to I'm only
going to program one this is another key
um so I'm just going to program this one
it is not working as you guys see it's
kind of a bad key it's dead but I was
just using my old my own personal cars
key to program it just to get my my
friend uh to uh see if the car is the
problem where the key is so it turned
out to be the key so anyways let's go to
immo so first of all you got to connect
your uh Maxi flash or if you're using a
programmer tablet like the km 100 which
will do the work just fine just connect
the VCI right there in OBD port and it
should read it so I'm going to go ahead
and click on accept
Infinity so automatic selection turn on
the hazards
and we're going to open and close the
driver turn on the ignition condition
cannot be turned on it can be but in
your case let's just see it cannot so
click on
okay okay so the system is done loading
so let's go to hot functions you don't
need to go to IMO status whatever it is
if you have BCM codes actually why not
I'm just going to show you click on IMO
status it's going to scan make sure that
the BCM doesn't have any St stupid codes
or something that's going to prevent it
from registering a key so as guys can
see number of registered Keys is blah
blah blah right here it's number one uh
encrypted code this is the code for this
specific
BCM so I'm just going to wait until it's
done at 87 uh
percent I know what taking a
while come
on cool we're done so I'm going to go
ahead and you can access it from here it
doesn't really matter but I'm going to
go to escape and I'm going to go to hot
functions although I can set as ICI
saided we can still do it from there uh
smart key learning so it's going to get
the
pin uh blah blah blah we don't need to
do any of that just click on
okay turn off the ignition the ignition
is in fact off open and close the door
and keep the hazards
on okay
okay cool it opened the steering lock
and so insert a smart key into the card
to learn so this is the key that I want
to insert right
here right there so and turn on the
ignition right there so the ignition
turned on we going to go to insert smart
key cool we're going to click on
okay turned on theone flash for you guys
so remove the smart key from the key
slot instrument cluster should go off so
I'm going to remove it boom it went
right off this is the key click on okay
insert this Marky to be learned in a key
slot and turn ignition does a security
indicator and dashboard flash five times
so what this means is that after it
flashes five times it will be basically
programmed so I'm going to turn it
on 1 2 3 4 5 now it's learned we're
going to click on yes
program success continue to program next
one yeah I might as well I'm going to
program it
moove this put this right here I'm going
to keep this key which is a good key to
be learned regardless remove and the
blah blah blah it did go off okay insert
this Marquee to be learned and it should
flash five times after I turn on the
ignition 1 2 3 4 5
boom process uh blah blah blah no I
don't want to program next one
remove this Mary from the key slot
instrument cluster should go off I don't
know if that's going to oops lost the
key but yeah it did actually turn off so
going to do this insert a learn smart
key into the key slot and turn on the
ignition for 3
seconds now this damn near never works
one 2
3 right here all
right oh I did okay so okay remove the
blah blah blah
it's saying once I remove it it will go
off but it actually doesn't I don't know
why it does that however it's programmed
so learning complete we're good to
go oh okay all right cool so I'm going
to make sure that it's working I'm going
to turn off the ignition and this is the
good key the well they're both good just
one is just a little bit better it's
open right there it locks unlock and we
have the other key right here which
actually does work cool all right so
they're both working they're good to go
this car has a starting issue so I'm not
going to attempt to start it it's going
to start if in your case you have a
perfectly running mechanic mechanically
perfectly running car but this is the
procedure this is how you do it super
simple as I said you don't need the
im608 Pro 2 you can just get a any im608
any I think any good xhorse or uh xtool
propad or any programmer uh the km100 is
probably your best bet for cars like
this it's 500 books and you get to use
it for many other cars so thank you guys
so much for watching have a wonderful
night bye-bye